we follow his show every single day on
uh peacock on nbc sports on peacock
completing the home and home i was on
his show earlier today now here on the
rich eisen show dan patrick how are you
dp
good afternoon rich good afternoon to
you sir um are you you asked for my take
on the thursday night opener now uh
let's uh let's reverse course here
what's your what was your takeaway from
the thursday night opener dan i went
into the game thinking dallas could win
the game
not keep it close i thought they could
truly win the game i don't know why i
thought that because if i listen to
every analyst i would have thought that
it would have been a double digit
blowout dallas to me was the better team
last night they didn't take advantage of
the opportunities and i know that comes
with the being a better team you do take
advantage but you know you had tampa and
tampa had turnovers had penalties
and you had them you've missed a couple
of field goals missed an extra point
and um i mean that's why tom brady is
who he is that he doesn't let these
opportunities kind of flitter away
and dallas is you know hopefully going
to learn from this i you know we know
what tampa is all about uh we're not
quite sure what dallas is all about
certainly on the other side of the ball
but if i'm a cowboys fan i feel pretty
good today that we went toe to toe at
least offensively with the buccaneers
and that that's a really good defense
and any questions that you had about
dak's leg or his worthiness of the big
fat contract you can check those boxes
yes i mean you got no problems now i
mean that was terrific what a great way
for him to come out of the box
but i don't want him throwing nearly 60
times a game right um
like that concerns me of a surgically
repaired ankle and you have a shoulder
that may be
you know that condition may be there all
season long and he's throwing that many
times
unless you're going to use
uh ezekiel elliott is sort of that his
safety valve that you know part of our
offense is like the patriots would use
their running backs to catch little you
know
uh dump patterns out to the right or the
left maybe they do that with zeke if
they're not going to use him as a a true
running back but
you know i
i was kind of surprised with the the
game plan there but it was enough to
keep him in the game and and maybe even
win that game well i think the front
center seven of of tampa dictated in a
way to kellen moore or they just decided
yeah that's just not working in the
first quarter screw it you know let's
see let's just turn dak loose and and go
after the the tender part of the defense
in the back and but you're right at some
point that that they're gonna have to
just
dedicate themselves zeke's getting 20
touches no matter what period yeah and
the story you know well i would never
have resigned him i i just don't believe
in giving my running back a a second
contract i just i don't want to do it a
minute no no no no no not at all now i
understand you know chris mccaffrey is
unique
and uh you know he's the uh the face of
the franchise there but you know saquon
barkley
going to have you know real question
here to i think you can find running
backs
unless you're baltimore you know right
there they're going through the rolodex
here but i just we have so many stories
of running backs where you go where'd he
come from i don't remember him in
college there's probably no other
position skill position where you say
that now you might say wide receiver
uh but you'd never say it about
quarterback
um but when it comes to running back
you're like oh yeah that guy was in
memphis you're like all right and you
know he's he's giving you quality
touches there so
no i don't i don't wanna unless you are
the titans and and derrick henry and i
in but once again are you gonna be able
to count on him for fifteen sixteen
seventeen hundred yards
and that's why i think bringing in julio
jones that helps maybe lessen the load
on derek henry and then when you get to
the playoffs you're gonna win you can
run the football and play good defense
uh but no i i would never have resigned
zeke elliott running backs being
fungible that sounds like a very
belichicking way of going are you like
the bill you have you're like bill are
you like bill right here i know you tell
fritz to do your job quite a lot but i
mean
it sounds like that's a very
belichicking way of building a team dan
well right
rich i think the uh
the results
so
well done dan patrick everybody here
thank you thank you very good very good
um so your super bowl prediction is once
again neither of the teams from last
night correct
kansas city in green bay and believe it
or not i had to talk myself out of
taking the titans
okay i don't i don't know why i kept i
was like they won't leave me they i
can't quit the titans for some reason
and i i have no affiliation with them
uh you know i i like mike rabel you got
two good wide receivers they were one of
the highest scoring offenses tana hill
was underrated you got derek henry
they
you know they went toe to toe with the
chiefs two years ago
um you know but dupree
caleb farley defense a little better
you're playing in the nfc i don't know i
couldn't right i couldn't shake them i
just couldn't and i thought i was going
to take the rams in the titans yes
and then i thought well the rams are
going to be in a division where
everybody's going to beat up on one
another and it might be just a battle of
attrition there and i i looked at green
bay with that division minnesota
probably will be a mess
uh detroit's not good chicago could be
interesting but probably not good
and you might be able to pick off some
wins there you know the chiefs don't
have a little tougher run in that
division i i think the broncos are are
better than advertised i don't know
about the raiders and then you have the
chargers who uh i think are a playoff
caliber team i agree and uh
that was incredibly impressive dan and
i'm addressing my guys here in the
studio take notes as i have been around
dan for a long time that was a man who
just gave you a super bowl prediction
but
has in his back pocket right i've
thought of the titans and the rams like
you just you now are on four teams while
also giving a super bowl prediction
that's
next
level broadcasting dan
i i'm you know
and i also i've been proud of the browns
yeah because you could say like i should
have listened to myself because i i knew
about the titans i should have listened
to me i said the rams i should have gone
but if it's chief's package you had it
all along impossible i mean i could say
thank god i didn't listen to my yeah
right
and if those are the teams that they
play and like that's what you want you
want those teams
in the championship games that the
chiefs and the packers beat because then
you're now covered the entire chessboard
dan oh that's what you you're set
yourself up for success
yep very well done uh i think that's
terrific um so what did you make of cam
newton's comments uh in an interview
with his dad
um that that he would have uh happily
been the backup in new england but
uh new england feared that he would uh
be a distracting presence to mack jones
looking over his shoulder essentially
would you make those comments down now
he might be the ultimate team player
he's really be loved and respected in
that locker room by all accounts but
here's the issue when mac jones throws
an interception what is the reaction
shot they're going to show if you're the
director right cam newton let's say he
has a bad game bill goes to the press
conference coach given a thought to uh
having cam newton no mike jones is my
starter every time that happens let's
see has a couple of bad games together
and then all of a sudden you're gonna
have cam and could can play
cam cameras is a distraction but it it's
because he's got a big personality and
we know that he's not the kind of guy
who's just going to stand there on the
sidelines and go you know what i'm good
if this is my career as a backup
quarterback i just i can't see that but
cam it strikes me as i would rather not
play
and and actually be out of uniform than
to be in uniform and not play
so he's right and belichick saw that
coming and he's just telling the truth
yeah i think so right now he says that
mac jones didn't beat him out
um
i think to the contrary i think i don't
i don't think cam realized what was
going on it's like when a guy i remember
going out on a date one time okay
many many years ago
a couple decades story time many decades
ago yes sir and
i was meeting a girl for the first time
and a
friend showed up
and next thing i know
my friend is dating the girl that i went
out
and to make it even worse they're making
out at the table
while i'm there
i think that's sort of what happened
well
not literally but that's sort of what
happened with mac jones they were
macking mac and
bill belichick were like i love you uh i
love you too
what do we do about him that's okay he
won't be around and next thing you know
it's like uh i'm gonna get rid of cam so
i was more surprised that they cut him
not that mac jones won the job how about
you well when that first happened i
thought uh the story had to have been
certainly because belichick earlier in
the day
said uh in a press conference that cam
was moving in the right direction and i
guess that meant the door you know
[Laughter]
and um and so i thought putting it all
together cam had said you know hey look
this is just not for me here which is a
totally understandable
approach like i i i don't want to be a
backup i'm in my early 30s i'm just six
years removed from being a most valuable
player in this league i understand you
know you wanting to go with your rookie
um
you know that's just not for me and i
thought like they were like go find
another job let's not hold you back i
honestly thought that was it but boy was
i way off
based on what cam is saying yeah but
when you say six years removed from an
mvp it seems like a long
six years removed from being the mvp
while i'm fascinated by him
i just in today's nfl i
unless you're lamar jackson i i just
can't have my quarterback be out there
and be a little erratic
and his best weapons are his legs and uh
i i just i think that offensive
philosophy doesn't work with bill bill
has so many running backs in new england
he doesn't need his quarterback to be a
running back and i think mac jones they
already had this system for twenty years
all they do is go on let's just plug and
play and let's run what we ran before
rely on the running backs for little
passes out of the backfield rely on your
tight ends occasionally take a you know
deep throw down the field you know just
uh go you know tom brady uh 2.0
dan patrick here on the rich eisen show
who are your sleeper teams one in each
conference if you had to choose a
sleeper team one in the afc one in the
nfc
would they be well the titans are a
sleeper team
no dan this is my way of giving you two
more opportunities
and you can even then say they were my
sleeper team and they made the super
bowl this is me just trying to widen out
the splash zone area for you now i i you
know what i've already widened the net i
i i've taken liberties with this and i
don't want to make a total mockery of
this so i i i've already
are you saying you have pride on this
subject matter dan yes
yes
yes
titans and the rams are my sleeper teams
okay yeah yeah yeah well i mean they're
teams that you have to the chargers are
or one of my sleeper teams i'm going to
say it later on i'm kind of revealing it
right here see i've got all the chargers
before really like today i mean let me
let me tell you did
i like to go to a 12-step recovery
program with them because every year
felt like they had the most talent but
there was always injuries and they found
ways to lose games and as much as i love
their head coach again their quarterback
is talented yes and you got a couple
very good defensive players
uh some sneaky offensive players i i've
learned my lesson i as much as i i'd
like them to make the playoffs i just
can't go
all in on what is a sleeper team so then
who's your mvp prediction for this year
i said mahomes just because i i i think
we we expect so much now josh allen was
oh my god
he's he's he's up there for the mvp
right then when you're supposed to win
the mvp
you don't it's really hard to go i'm
going to live up to the expectations and
i could make a case
that josh allen was as valuable to
buffalo as aaron rodgers was to green
bay last year right
because
josh allen did everything he had step on
digs but i didn't think they had a great
offensive line i didn't think that you
know the running game wasn't great
i just think there's so much hype and
pressure on him
and it's really hard to live up to those
expectations i don't think rogers could
put up something
that would be an encore performance
where the voters would go and we're
going to give him back-to-back mvps
i think mahomes
sort of goes hey guys remember me and
you know puts up 55 touchdown passes
this year and uh
he's going to be the mvp it's very rare
that somebody's in there what uh fourth
or fifth year
and we're already saying yeah it's
already assumed he's the best let's give
it to somebody else like you know where
they'll never like belichick could be
set up for a coach of the year type
campaign rookie quarterback right yeah
and totally changing the roster and if
they win the division would anybody name
bill belichick coach of the year like
never that will never happen because you
know he's already considered the modern
day lombardi i think we view mahomes
like that he is my mvp choice as well i
think he's going to light it up
and he could even threaten you know 60.
it's entirely possible for him to throw
well
i don't bill jackson may have won coach
of the year once or twice right uh chuck
noll i don't think ever won coach of the
year in the nfl
we we don't honor
those who have talent are supposed to
win but it's really hard to win when
you're expected to win we love the story
that comes out of nowhere where you go
wow he did a great job with that team
even at seven in nine last year i
thought belichick did an unbelievable
job you know he he got guys who opted
out and you had cam who couldn't throw
any somehow i mean they were really
close to making the playoffs and
you know it i know that people don't
want to hear that belichick did a great
job and they went 7-9 but in my mind it
truly did a great job last year dp
appreciate the time really i always
cherish it thank you brother by the way
when you were on the air last night i
was talking to your wife
she did
i just want to let you know yeah it's
not related to the story previously that
you told um but no uh it
i heard that story what were you uh what
were you talking about dan
well i'm gonna leave it up to your wife
if she wants to tell you but i i just as
a friend i wanted to let you know i
didn't want to let you know when you
were on the air i had i wanted to let
you know
she did say that to me when i called
after i went off here she goes yeah i
just got off the phone with dan i'm like
oh great all right texting susie oh
great oh great
and i don't even know how long we uh
spoke for uh let me see
let me look at it here
uh
17 minutes we spoke for 17. well she's
an
excellent conversationalist dan and you
know who's calling me right now
no no no no no hold on
susie's
mom is that right right now so this must
be right now right this minute it just
came up susie's mom
and uh so your wife's mom i don't know
what's going on i mean i thought we had
we had a nice conversation last night
yes yep you know yep your her mom is
calling okay say hi to her mother for me
okay
no you don't have to no yeah no tell her
i said hello oh okay i appreciate it dad
you're okay you bring families together
dan patrick bringing families together
bringing families together
and then i got another super bowl pick
it's my mother-in-law versus the chiefs
very good bye guys
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here